welcome to this game playing pop wall 29
yep one of the frequent opponents have a
great score in Stern it's very high
rated here let me check is this one of
his best snowy 2 to 5
Carlos I Verado Rodriguez that son
doesn't sound very polish funny ok I
gather it goes and this is really in
line that is totally in fashion people
really tend to play what the top guys
play it says just like that well there's
some logic to it today normally play
good lines
I had this right I had this just very
briefly a very short time ago
it's their night chicks before a night
xd4 here if I Castle twin before word
looks funky
Claire don't see a trick here you can
take c3 play Knight e5 for this kind of
business I can take with the pawn sorry
and it's not even that favorable anyway
I probably have to move the Coronet at
some point anyway
Oh Queen e6 that looks kind of strange
Wow
okay hmm
twin b3 maybe just detective hive 97
blunders the bishop so it probably has
to take it yeah and that's really not
what you want hmm
okay pawn takes or queen takes after
Queen takes as pieces look kinda
misplaced for b4 b5 not sure B takes was
possible Knight a5 then there's a funny
piece placement Queen d6 and Bishop on
d7 but of course this is a very solid
position you can play let's say rook c8
yep 97 this kind of thing is possible
[Music]
the good thing for widest it plays
itself very easy can play this very
easily don't have to spend much time
there for control for complex
considerations it's just fairly
straightforward twin side plane haha
okay so I can go b6 here Y can take it's
both interesting okay let's take
[Music]
96
maybe I can just take this thing for 95
I wonder Knight you have f6
am I going to take on c6 it's not that
bad
it looks weird to take the bishop but
but it's still a good structure I can go
before here but doesn't really help
probably maybe this move your pin
setting up a pin Wow what you're not
losing this pawn before that's hard to
believe
let's see that looks like a very
lonesome warrior there on before ready
to be picked up
plus there's a six as a possible threat
now rook b1 yes
okay so if I take before bouquet eight I
have a six yes there is no back ranked
stuff going on right
no a six I could have taken maybe I
should have taken c6 if he goes back
with the bishop now okay it will do a
business it will still be good okay Jake
and rupees six okay so this is kind of
niacin I've got total control him
make sure not getting getting mated he's
maybe going all the way to c7
I can try to enter with the king or
probably where it's all very nicely
nicely organized I can trade one rook
maybe two through p8 go from them using
the King here for some activity rook
could be seven maybe Knights 97's may be
coming okay let's put it in it's also
not bad now going to advance
I really try check okay hmm yeah okay
it's not a change at that and it's
varying me too much the age porn is is a
good a good target or possibly F 3d form
hmm but how how do I actually win lots
it's not that easy a seven yeah probably
a seven rupee aid time for something
something decisive time warning
[Music]
switching attention to the kingside
where there's the second weakness on age
six
this is why g5 was a move that I didn't
mind so much I needed something else to
attack him
no no Bishop f5 is a very inconvenient
threat don't really see what she does
about that King on the seventh is rook
h7 that's actually deadly well that said
he has no move Bishop f5 is is winning
next next move
no out out over and out
it's an eternal pin he has absolutely he
can he doesn't have a movement super
swung almost black resigned okay I'm
glad was a nice game I really like that
having control for most of it I think
okay so he went with the strange move
and takes takes and yeah I was just a
little bit better long term oops that
was the wrong button it's just a matter
of yeah how he sets up against the the
queenside um aggression
yeah a five I know I probably would have
taken getting stuff traded the a porn is
it's more reliability but yeah this is
very difficult to decide I decided to
take yeah and he had just it's just that
those pawns are weaker then then my my
my pawns okay I just I will take on g6
35 and at some point maybe he was afraid
of that but now I'm centralizing yeah
and I think this is a mistake
this pawn is going to be going to be
very weak okay the computer is not
agreeing
it gives Bishop e8 as equal kind of
shocked why is this equal he's just
about rooks III because of f6
some some kind of weird tactic rooks III
that's strong
that's a strong strong move just now a
bit awkward you probably have to move
the bishop and then this f6 or Luke a3
and ever six one one big point is that
he all of a sudden gets gets this Bishop
out hmm that's that's really really
remarkable I was really thinking that
this should just be good the comp is
giving this one just trading a 4b pawn
which is yeah okay that is good for
white because those pawns are weak but I
was thinking a5 is just convenient yeah
I'm keeping the pawn and and getting
that before but yeah this was a great
resource
Bishop e8 yeah that's a move yeah okay
certainly can be found by a human player
but in with little time another comp
actually gives me an edge anyway because
of this this is a bit more precise now
this idea 0.4 mmm yeah but that would
have been much much better and this is
just winning I guess looks very very
nice yeah now I can go here first or
take c6 that's a very nice endgame g4 is
a good move I think fixing orders here
on dark squares and giving me invasion
squares for the king and yeah I had the
idea to trade one pair of rooks you can
debate about that not sure those two
rooks look very passive but I want to
use my king actively and very often you
want to trade one pair of rooks before
you do that I think I'm keeping an
advantage here rupees six King up check
and now I have a second weakness on age
six he went here and now okay you can
play probably also different moves but
this is a very clean solution I believe
we win this pawn and in this competition
he's in a deadly pin so that was a good
technical game despite this one moment
where he could have defended I don't
mind that very much it's it's difficult
to see a bishop e8 especially this come
on
and with this f6 Bishop d6 idea yeah as
mentioned with some time on your hands
okay but in a blitz game okay I don't
mind if I overlook this kind of resource
yeah okay thanks for watching